welcome to what's new in networking a
series to keep you up to date with
well what's new in networking this is
stephanie wong and today we'll be
covering our core
infrastructure updates we'll cover some
new shared vpc capabilities as well as
new mtu settings for interconnect so
stay tuned
[Music]
shared vpc provides the ability for
organizations to connect resources from
multiple service projects
to a common vpc this is amazing as it
provides
centralized control over networking
resources like subnets routes and
firewall rules
and it was great for vms with a single
nic but
it wasn't ideal for vms which require
nik 0
to be a non-shared vpc network this
means something like this was
not supported nik 0 would be tied to the
local vpc
while nick one would be assigned to the
shared vpc
to support this customers would have to
deploy proxies to front-end the
instances
which led to more management and
resource overhead
with this recent launch we now support
shared vpc
on a non-default nic now you can attach
a shared bpc to
any nic of an instance and this
eliminates the requirement of proxies
and gives more flexibility for
vm configurations and now on to
mtu mtu stands for maximum transmission
unit the size of the largest protocol
data unit that can be communicated in a
single network layer transaction
a larger mtu can bring greater
efficiency because each network packet
carries more data
while protocol overheads like headers
remain fixed
1500 bytes mtu is an industry standard
ipacket size
the default mtu for google cloud vpc is
1460 bytes
as of the end of 2020 you're now able to
increase the mtu
to 1500 bytes while this gave vms the
ability to exchange 1500 byte ip packets
with other vms
services or the public internet there
was still a discrepancy with cloud
interconnect
which provides direct physical
connections between your on-premise
network and
google's network prior to this launch
google cloud
interconnect mtu was set to 1440 bytes
with this new launch we now support
end-to-end 1500 byte ntu support
organizations can lift and shift or
support hybrid workloads
with strict mtu requirements
and that's what's new in networking for
core infrastructure
let us know in the comments if you think
these will accelerate and improve your
cloud journey
be sure to take a look at the links
below for details and guides on how to
use them
and stay tuned for the latest launches
in our next category on
what's new in networking
you